νόλας οσταντίνος που είναι όο στα πολιτική έρχονται να ζητήσουν τη γνώμισα στη συμβουλή ε
πόρι να μου ναι π να συζητήσουμε κάποια πράματα σίγουρα αλλά πλέο νομίζω ότιεναι οι
ίδιοι που πρέπει να πάγον ταις αποφάσεις τους εκείνα που πιστεύουν ότι είνες ως το
ξεω ότι μεταξύ τους σίγουρα συζητούν και σαντιανάστασία εί να που την υπολογίζουν ότι έχει
κάποια καλήκρίση για πανώσε αυσάτα θέματα να τη ζητήσουν η τη γνώμη της αλλά αντάξειεγώ
λέω τα πράματα που πιστεύω ελά επε εκεί και εκεί ονικό λας αδιοκήθηκε όταν προσπάθησε
για πρώτε ημογράτιαθεωρείται είναι δενξέω αναδικήθηκε με την ένια αλλά έγιναν πολλά παιχνίδια τότε καιδυστυχώς
ντιπαραθέσεις που έγιναν και από το διήγο καιτάξει τα άλλα ακόμματα φυσικώ να θέλουν να
πολεμήσουν ίσως να έπαιρξαν κάποιο γολοι στο τηνεν εμπσε να εκλαιγει τουλάιστον να πάει στο
δευτερογείο ανέλθει σήμερα αποσταντίνως και σας πει σκέφτομε για το κοιοκτό τι θα το απαντήσετε
πρέπει α το σκεφτόπραγματικά ναι εγώ ίσας είπα θα πό ότη γνώμημου αλλά απε καικαι
εκεί ο καθένας αναλαμβάνει ταις ευθύνες του η ρώτησε έγινε και α μάδο πουλού γιατί
ξέρε είμαστε στην κύπρο μικρή χώρα όλι λένε ακούγετα πως απαντάτεσει τις φήμες και θα
και στα όσα λένε κάποιο ότι πίσω από τις αποφάσεις τον παιδιό της και ασμαραδοπούλου
είναι κύρί αφοτινή ότι η κυρία ο